Hawaii mosquitoes don't seem as bad as
California mosquitoes Island like yeah
they're brought us they get it they
brought
[Music]
us all right guys what is
this spin everybody knows what it is
it's notorious got very very popular I
think in
2017 was it to help people with ADHD or
something that they can f or anxiety or
something where they can focus yeah I
think that was one part of the narrative
but I also think just like fun it's
literally for people who just need to
fidget with something these got really
crazy too there was like boxes and you
see the the fidget cubes I like that
yeah those cubes I was like always
messed around with that you know they're
just called fidgets now right there's a
whole category of toys called fidgets
and there's like little poppy things and
like like ta always like look at all my
fidgets oh wow oh really he has some he
likes them has a whole box of fidgets
well the woman who created the fidget
spinner hasn't earned a single penny off
of her creation no way
why did she not is she mad about it or
what it let me show you how
good where do you go from there I'm like
you should have patented it before
releasing it then well let me give you a
full story before you talk [__] I'm
never talking [__] all right that's how
sweet then she she looks like your
stereotypical Elementary School teacher
yeah I feel like we all had her as a as
a teacher fourth grade yeah yeah very
very sweet lady anyways
um her name is Catherine hinger okay the
she is the toys original inventor um she
actually was never able to cash in on it
because when she invented this she came
up with the original idea for the the
the fidget spinner not like any of the
break offs or anything like that right
back in
1993 she tried to pitch it to a number
of toy retailers including Hasbro but
they all of them turned her down wow she
got a patent for her invention in 19
1997 all right but by 2005 it expired
and she couldn't afford the $400 renewal
fee to hold on to the rights of the
device oh my God your Pat expire yeah
patents expire what's the timeline well
there's certain ones where like it's
like after like a 100 years anybody
could use it and that's the controversy
behind Disney cuz a Mickey Mouse it
should be already like at that point but
they keep finding ways to making it
theirs extend wow
y so fast forward to 2014 a dude named
Scott MC mosery invented something he
called the torque bar which is a fidget
spinner what a terrible name he said he
invented it because he wanted something
to focus his hands on during meetings at
work so he wouldn't fidget as much while
his boss droned on and a few years later
it [__] skyrocketed in popularity the
[__] a torque bar a fidget spinner but
that's what he called it bad name he
repented or and now he's a billionaire
is it like a website where you park the
domain and then like if it expires
someone else can buy the domain like can
someone just literally submit someone
else's Blueprints and say that expired
I'm going to I don't think you could
submit exactly somebody else's blueprint
I but the like the likeness of it yeah I
think the idea is that you let's say I
came up with an invention and maybe you
coincidentally also came up with an
invention right I would have to search
and patent it first is all you know what
I mean I actually tried to go through
one of those I tried to make a [__]
water spray comb and I went inside the
whole office and they said it's going to
cost about 12 Grand and I was like well
my question is yeah 12 Grand to get it
started patent it my question is uh has
anybody else built it and he showed me a
book full of that same idea wow in
different various ways what's the water
spray
cone I'm going do it so um pretty much
what it is it you can connect it to any
water bottles yeah but you could like
spray and comb it at the same time have
like Barber Barber yeah cuz I'm a barber
out oh one of many jobs but also just
for people who who just need something
to go real quick it was just going to be
a smaller little bottle of hairspray or
water whatever you know the new sprays
that barbers use it's next level when
that come on the mark yeah cuz before
it's like right now the new ones it's oh
yeah yeah I have that one too it's like
a hydro it's like a hydrop pump or
something right here yeah shit's getting
lit right now I know you guys ever uh
semi invented something wanted to patent
it I don't think I'm smart like that I
bought a book on how to get inventions
and patent it properly and all that the
step by steps you join a gang after I
got it at the thrift store for a dollar
really did you learn anything cool from
it I didn't open it yeah I bought
it I haven't G through it yet when I
read through it I'll tell you I bought
it put it in my suitcase and I flew here
Jo you down let's let's let's do it I
will just give me some
time stop rushing the process dude I got
to read the
book and then I'll well we'll come up
with inventions we'll have some
inventions you know what I want to sell
have you ever seen like it's like so
during the'80s right Japanese inventors
came up with all these funny like
outlandish things they were just
shooting they were just cranking them
out and there's ones where like they had
fullon prototypes with advertisements
for and you're like this has to be a
[__] joke oh yeah yeah I've seen some
it's like chopsticks with fans on it so
they can eat ramen and it's like blowing
it glasses that like catch your tears
when you're crying or something yeah
it's a crazy [__] like way too Niche
it's so stupid but I'm like I actually
think a lot of those things would sell
now just for the laugh oh yeah a gag
gift store
I'm looking at crazy inventions yeah I
don't think I ever I don't the dude P
it and he made all the money I think he
made a bunch of money off damn damn and
she's not well this is a big bang better
mouse trap it's a mouse trap but instead
of it the thing going it's there's a gun
that gets triggered and it shoots the
mouse sh oh
[__] damn so when you hear it you're
just like another one that's [__]
wild dude what are her thoughts on the
pop is she just happy that it's being
used she yeah she's just a sweet old
lady or very classic kindergarten
teacher type thing about it despite not
being able to cash in on the craze and
struggling for money herself she's still
struggling for money apparently D she's
a lot she said back in 2017 that she's
pleased that people are enjoying the
things she created you know why because
she tried patent patenting it once right
yeah and then when the renewal came up
she couldn't afford it so I think she's
just trying to cope with it she was like
I it liar hey you know what we can do we
got to find a way to get rid of like
mosquitoes like you know a [__] like
that the little machine over there if we
could find the more efficient way
mosquito to get rid of these little
ankle biting mosquitos dude we could be
[__] trillionaires dog don't they
have the thing where you could light it
up and start that [__] kind of works but
it doesn't really work like it doesn't
really work that well the tanella or
whatever the green box it's a green box
and incense it's like an incent but it
keeps mosquitoes away smells [__] like
no way that could be good for you though
right that's what I was thinking that
[__] that [__] is killing you you're
breathing toxic yeah raid I'm like if it
kills that getting on my that's probably
bad for me yeah guys [__] I had a
blasting in my room I'm so down for
mosquito genocide yeah like if we could
find a way to commit better you what the
easiest thing to do is moov to Vegas see
but Steve Green came over here this fo
lives next so artificial Lake yeah
outside of where he lives wait till you
get your there's literally no yeah
there's no mosquitoes all right we'll
see dude oh yeah you have chlorine treat
a he has Turtles and [__] [__] nikk had
a story about all the mosquitoes too
yeah cuz they live next to they have
Turtles and [__] they live next to
yeah 90% of so that's who we sell to bro
we sell to people who live by giant
bodies of water and need mosquito idah
are we would pay top dollar for like a
really effective that's what I'm saying
that's non-toxic and you get cuz every
time I hear a fly going into the little
bug zapper it's just like a sexual
pleasure makes so happy cuz now cuz
during at the gym dude we have these
little rackets the electric rackets and
the whole time we're just trying to kill
mosquitoes and flies and it's a [__]
dude just use a
fan does that work yeah the
mosquit big ones that guy with a big old
swamp fan and then he has like a net and
then he just shows like a bag of
mosquitoes oh my God and he's just like
it's just the fan blowing it in and then
they come from outside and get sucked up
and then they get hit by the wire that's
it I want to I want to watch that that
would be like pimple popping videos to
me there's like a weird satisfaction for
the just absolute murder ofo
mosquitoes me watching that video would
make
meum Kum Kum by dude D definitely I got
bit uh two nights
ago within a span of like 3 minutes I
got six bites and you know when they
bite you it doesn't hurt it's after they
leave like a minute later you're like
and it bugs you for 2 weeks but luckily
I just came back from Japan and Japan
has the best [__] afterbite mosquito
thing it's like with a little blue cap
you know what I'm talking about menol
yeah it's like Menthol and you just
[__] press it on not itching no more
menthol solves all yo [__] legitimate
every time I go to Japan I always buy
mosquitoes can you buy some for me next
time okay how about we just make our own
I like itching it let's make got to go
check the patents yeah you got a good
Menthol guy the satisfaction but then it
just gets worse and worse I ha but then
sometimes it's so itchy it wakes you up
in your sleep and that's when I hate it
cuz you're sleeping like a God dang oh
that's the worst though when you sleep
and you hear them don't yeah cuz now you
know you're [__] the worst is when
you're about to go to sleep and you see
one and you're like oh no I'm going hard
I'm going to do my best to catch that
[__] just leave your phone light on and
just wait and it'll go and you go
[__] [__] after thought they
watch your they can see through your
temperature and your body is that how
they [__] get you through your
clothes man bastards in Houston they can
those [__] are big over there
yeah see I got bit through my shirt in
Houston I think that's the key guys is
that's how we become billionaires we
find a way to kill these these
mosquitoes the older I got though um um
like not immune but I don't itch as long
yeah yeah I just get it the first day
and I'm like ow and I go like swim in
the beach and it's gone the next day
salt water baby maybe that's what it is
yeah every time I'm on a hike I get hit
by a mosquito and then later I'm just it
doesn't even mess me up that Hawaii
mosquitoes don't seem as bad as
California mosqu Island life dude yeah
they brought us they get it they brought
us yeah maybe they just suck enough
blood just to chill out okay they're not
greedy like La yeah yeah greedy ass La
mosquito mosquitoes
dude